>> So, good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Eshan Sadasivan,
and I'm the founder and CEO of
PROSOC Innovators
Private Limited.
I have Mr. Shreeshan,
who is our technical team member.
First of all, I
would like to thank
both MSRA and Samhita for
giving us this opportunity
to present over here.
We're a for-profit
social enterprise.
I'm clearly stating,
we're not NGO.
We're a for-profit
social enterprise.
PROSOC stands for
Products for Society.
We are a product
innovation company
that is trying to design and
develop innovative products to
serve the people in
bottom of pyramid.
So, our first product
is in education domain,
where we have developed
a school bag that can become
a study table for
those underprivileged
students who sit on
floor and study with
bad body posture.
Our second product is
in livelihood domain,
where it's a compact, low cost,
paper carry bag making machine to
mass produce paper carry bags
as an alternative to
polythene carry bags.
So, this compact machine,
this low-cost machine,
is going to create
numerous employment
opportunities to
rural women as well as
physically challenged people.
So, these are our two products.
DESKIT, the school bag,
is in education domain.
The paper bag making machine
is in livelihood domain.
But today, I am pitching
here for our third product,
which is in agriculture domain.
This product is being
headed by Mr. Shreeshan.
So, in agriculture domain,
we are trying to build a machine
to segregate areca nut.
Areca nut is this,
supari, what we call.
To tell a bit about PROSOC,
we started our journey
from IIT Kanpur.
We got the company incubated
in IIT Kanpur SIDBI
Incubation Center.
We started it in October 2015.
So, next month, we'll be
turning three years old.
For now, we have
one product in market,
DESKIT, the school bag.
Paper bag machine, we'll be
launching in January 2019,
three months down the line.
The areca nut machine,
the R and D has started,
and we are seeking
now support from MSRA
and other eligible partners
who can help us
develop this product.
So, this is areca nut.
So, it's a commercial
crop in India,
and India is the
number one producer
of areca nut in the world.
India produces 49.5 percent
of world's areca nut.
So, areca nut, from a tree,
this is the kind of fruit we get.
Once it's harvested, once
the processing is done,
we get 12 types of areca nut,
as the box is being circulated.
So, there are 12 types
of areca nut,
which are produced
from a single tree.
Now, a farmer who is
growing areca nut,
if he can segregate this into
12 different types and
sell in the market,
he can earn more money.
Back in old days,
what used to happen,
they used to have
manual segregation of
these areca nut into
12 different types.
But nowadays, there is
huge shortage of labor.
They can't get people
to work for them.
So, there is this problem,
where if they can't segregate it,
they can't sell at
better price in the market.
So, they're incurring huge loss.
So, that's why farmers
are not finding
this particular
commercial crop as
an attractive alternative for
them to carry
their agriculture forward.
So, here, we are trying
to eliminate the problem
faced by farmers by
designing and developing
an image processing
based machine which can
segregate 12 different
types of areca nut
for them and make their job easy.
Also, the accuracy of
the machine is more,
and it eliminates
the shortage of labor.
Now, I would like
to call Shreeshan,
who would continue
the presentation.
>> Hello. Is it audible?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. I will explain
the process of segregation.
We have two cameras,
one from the top view and
another from the bottom view.
We need these two because
you can see in those type,
there are actually
two surfaces which
are having two different
characteristics.
That's why we need two cameras.
Once the image is captured,
it's sent to image
pre-processing unit,
where we remove the noise and
we change the aspect ratio,
and we convert it to corresponding
[inaudible] part and segment it.
Then, we feed into
a trained neural network model,
which classifies the areca nut
into corresponding surface.
Depending on the top view
and bottom view result,
we will come into conclusion
what type of
the areca nut is given.
Depending on that, we give
the control signal
to microcontrol,
which will segregate
the areca nut into 12 bins.
The 12 types of
areca nut are varied
from the changes in
their texture in both views,
and they are segregated
depending on that.
The texture, physique,
and colors differ from
one another so that
we can segregate.
For collecting the data,
we classified whole 12 types
into five different surfaces.
In five different surfaces,
only depending on the size
and the surface texture,
we will get 12 types.
We collected 700 image
for each surface so
that we got 3,500 images.
Using image augmentation
technique for each type,
we increase up to 2,000 images.
That's why we got 10,000 images.
Right now, we are using
Inception V3 model
for retraining,
in that we are getting
75 percent accuracy.
What we need is,
Inception V3 is trained for
classifying different objects,
like cycle, those defect
structure, object, and color.
That's why we can't use
Inception V3 anymore because
it gives less accuracy.
That's why we need a some, yeah,
which is trained on
segregation of similar objects
such as face recognition,
iris recognition.
Those can be retrained,
so that it will
give more accuracy.
We need inputs regarding
changing the preprocessing stage.
We are using only HSV segmentation
technique and some of
the OpenCV techniques to get
the areca nut crop to
the corresponding aspect ratio.
>> When we started this project
we visited many farmers.
We visited more than 70 farmers.
Areca nut is a commercial crop,
which is in India mainly grown in
three states: Karnataka,
Kerala, and Assam.
So, visited many farmers in
Karnataka as well as
Sogo Heart in Assam.
When we interacted with them,what
we got to know from them was,
to solve the problem of
labor shortage
they're facing today,
they are ready to pay
up to four lakh rupees,
to buy if a machine was
existing like that.
So, a customer is ready
to buy a machine,
which costs up to
four lakh rupees.
Because areca nut being
a commercial core crop,
they have good returns
on this crop.
So, they don't mind
investing this amount,
which can help them through
the process they have to do.
One more thing is, here we
are not looking for
support from MSRA or
support from Southern
California University.
Just for building
one algorithm for
one particular agricultural
product over here.
We want a general algorithm,
which can be finally
customized or advanced
as per requirement,
to suit to different
agricultural products
across the world and support
multiple products
or multiple farmers
for different
agriculture products.
Thus far, we are requesting
for an overall support,
so that we can have
a strong technology in place,
which can be implemented
as per the requirement.
We have got our grant
of 10 lakh rupees for
this particular project from
needy press came of
government of India,
for developing the mechanical
prototype of the machine.
So, we have some budget in
place to take care of
the mechanical prototyping,
but on the technology
development when
it comes to the coding and
the algorithm part,
there we need support.
One more thing is,
we recently happened
to get in discussion with
the Design Alpha people.
Design Alpha is a company
based South of Kochi.
So, they support
different startups to come up
with hardware prototypes
or hardware products.
So, we are in
discussions with them
on this particular product.
So, their expertise of
more than 30 years is
going to help us develop
the mechanical part of
this particular product.
So, we are looking for
this image processing and
neural networks support,
artificially region support,
so that this product
can become a reality.
>> I meant to ask,
what types of people
typically process areca nuts?
So, would it be
small household farmers
or cooperatives of farmers or
larger factories that have
middlemen giving them
nuts from farmers.
Can those processes typically
afford machines like that?
>> There are cooperative
societies called Mondays,
where the farmers
come their produce.
>> Those of the markets know?
>> Yeah. Mondays are the places
where the overall
segregation happens.
So, if this machine
will be ready,
the ideal target customer
will be the Monday owner.
Because this person
will be able to afford
a better speed and
better processing
capacity machine
at a better price point.
>> So, how many people work at
these Mondays doing this work?
>> Yeah, now event when
things areca nut
processing season.
There will be typically
50-60 women and men
laborers who will be
regularly employed.
So, that duration will be
for three to four
months in a year.
>> All right, what is
the other question?
>> One quick question.
You mentioned
that you have the
restrictions of who can
access like for Los Angeles
can be accessed?
>> Yeah, the images we accessed
have taken the images.
We can give the access to you,
or as if required we can
also take more images.
>> So, I have just a
meta comment which is
that overall goal
that you have of
classifying a crop is
very good, I think.
But, taking the example of
areca nut specifically may
not be a good example
of AI for social good.
Because areca nut is
the primary reason for
very high incidence of
oral cancer in India.
It is the primary reason.
>> But, mixed with
tobacco, then it'll cause.
>> No, no, no. So,
areca nut, I mean,
I come from Northeast,
very close to Assam.
It's widespread addiction.
So, it tobacco the incidence
increases by several fold,
but even without tobacco,
there is enough research
to show that
areca nut actually causes.
>> As a dentist, I can
give you some perspective,
not a technology person.
So, yes, areca nut
is one of the things
which ignites or accelerate
the carcinogenic, that's true.
So, but that is persist
areca nut what you get in pan,
cathar, supari, what you add.
But, this is like
the wholesale one,
with the shell intact and all.
So, it has some medicinal uses
also and if you presses it
down to that supari form,
removing the outer shell,
then it is one of
the things which
can lead to if you
constantly chew on you,
it causes irritation
to the oral mucosa,
and from there you can
get this blistered,
and it can gradually go
up to the carcinogen,
that's true.
But, they're talking about
wholesale crops here,
so that's something, which
was not a direct conflict a.
>> No, but who is
the user? What is the use?
>> So, what I'm
going to use this is
definitely the supari industry.
That I know I will not
chat in that obviously.
Other uses is also used
as a pain medication in
certain ointments in
bands on medicinal uses.
So, they're wide variety, but
that is also one of the uses,
one of the industries
who buys this.
So, I'm not going to
say that it's not.
But, yeah, but it is
not a direct causative,
tobacco is the number one cause.
This is one of the irritants,
which definitely leads to
fibrous jaw and then oral cancer.
Yeah, latest [inaudible] .
>> In addition with these,
actually what we observe in
the rural areas and
municipal schools,
see is supari and
that areca nut is a gateway
to know for addiction of tobacco.
So, children started no
masala supari wish supari and
then they started not like
consuming tobacco and etc.
So, whenever you're asked
questions to the childrens,
how you get addiction
of for tobacco,
so number of children says that
we started consuming through
supari and then we start
get addiction of tobacco.
So, if I'm wrong,
please correct me.